we start with a Fox News Alert if you're
like most Americans you didn't watch
today's impeachment charade here's the
big takeaway another huge dud and
frankly an embarrassing spectacle for
the entire country
now what Democrats are doing to this
country this is humiliating to all of us
a display that needs to come to an end
common sense reason intellectual honesty
ever played a part in any of this
nothing but one opinion after another
opinion after another opinion followed
by conjecture on the opinion and how my
feelings are about whatever no actual
evidence no wrongdoing whatsoever none
all of it every bit of it hearsay and
this person's interpretation and that
person's interpretation of the
transcript that we all read now this is
now blowing up in the Democrats face
Americans are tuning out in a big way
viewership of this public Sham dropped
by over a million from day one a day -
and I bet it dropped again today the
number of Americans watching already
pales in comparison to previous
proceedings the ratings were so bad CBS
News I predicted this they actually
decided to pull the plug on their
wall-to-wall coverage earlier today in
exchange for regular programming I would
expect other networks will probably
follow suit and according to a morning
console poll the first hearings were
utterly failed to increase any support
for this corrupt this compromise shift
show has net voter support for
impeachment and the inquiry yeah that's
not a new low also another polls showing
that over two-thirds of Americans they
have already made up their minds on the
subject but they know it all comes down
to the transcript there's no mystery
here at all despite what the Democrats
are trying to create an environment
circus about American people are smart
they can easily read the now public
transcript at the center of the ship
show and not one witness was necessary
not a single one and on that transcript
which you can read which today's
witnesses confirm was accurate and
complete not a single time how
interesting was the President of the
United States that
ever mention aid not one time to the
president of Ukraine in fact aid was
delivered in full it was delivered
without any conditions and it was
delivered with Ukraine having to do
nothing and did nothing to get the aid
there was no quid there was no pro
there's no quo and no pressure no
extortion how many more times does the
Ukrainian president have to say I didn't
have any problems with any of this the
Democrats new favourite poll-tested
allegation well maybe we won't call it a
quid pro quo as the Washington Post said
we'll change the name to bribery that's
what we'll do well that was only
mentioned once and that was in relation
to the real quid pro quo Joe Biden
remember oh you're not getting the money
you don't fire the prosecutor you don't
get the billion dollars you got six
hours if you fire the prosecutor who we
was told was investigating his zero
experience son then I'll give you the
billion okay why is this son being paid
millions of dollars no experience in
Ukraine no experience in oil gas or
energy oh because this son of the vice
president what's this
multiple Democratic members of this
committee gave TV and radio interviews
over this past week discussing how the
president's conduct supported his
impeachment for committing bribery for
the longest time this was all about
quid pro quo according to the
whistleblower complaint but after
witness after witness began saying there
was no quid pro quo or even that quid
pro quo was not even possible we saw a
shift from the Democrats it briefly
started to refer to the president's
conduct on the July 25th call as
extortion and now it shifted again last
week to bribery Ms Williams you didn't
you've never used the word bribery or
bribe to explain president Trump's
conduct correct yes sir colonel vinden
you have an either that is correct that
is correct instead of delivering any
proof of the president's new word
so-called bribery two of today's most
senior witnesses completely refuted that
claim no bribery no linkage whatsoever
between US aid and any
investigation none zero zip take a look
miss Morrison I'll start start with you
or did anyone ever asks you to bribe or
extort anyone at any time during your
time in the White House no sir and you
were the top person for Ukraine in the
White House correct at the NSC level I
would argue ambassador Bolton would be
by reporting to ambassador Bolton I was
a senior official yes sir
ambassador Volcker you have a storied
career were very thankful for your
service and you were the special envoy
to Ukraine that was correct did anyone
at the White House ever ask you to bribe
or extort anything out of anyone at any
time no sir
that's recap masseter Volcker zero
evidence of such a thing
top National Security Council Advisor
Tim Morrison no evidence didn't see it
every other witness zero evidence of
anything like bribery not even
mentioning the word on their own zero
times Democrats they want to impeach a
sitting president over this and yet they
won't even allow the person that started
this entire charade yet precious hearsay
non whistleblower whistleblower to
testify before Congress I have never
seen such madness or insanity in my
entire life that's 31 years following
politics and talk radio now my 24th year
at Fox that's saying a lot
and as ranking member Devin Nunez
pointed out there's a very good reason
that you have the compromised the
corrupt congenital liar Adam Schiff and
he wants to keep the whistleblower in
hiding there's a good reason for that
because he lied again take a look what
was the full extent of the
whistleblowers prior coordination with
chairmanship his staff and any other
people he cooperated with while
preparing the complaint what are the
whistleblowers political biases and
connections to democratic politicians
how does the whistleblower explain the
inaccuracies in the complaint what
contact did the whistleblower have with
the media which appears to be ongoing
what are the sources of the
whistleblowers information
who else did he talk to and was the
whistleblower prohibited by law from
receiving or conveying any of that
information and don't forget in
September yeah the compromised fact
witness congenital liar Adam Schiff
tweeted oh he looked forward to the
whistleblowers testimony went on MSDN
see the conspiracy television network we
have not spoken with directly with the
whistleblower but we would like to talk
to the whistleblower another lie by the
congenital liar and a short time after
well
media outlets reported that shifts
office in fact was actually meeting in
advising the non whistleblower hearsay
whistleblower from the beginning and
chief completely reversed his opinion oh
and no longer wanted the whistleblower
to testify and then yet another shocking
twist
well now the congenital liar well he
claims he knows nothing about the
whistleblowers identity you're following
along this is the level of insanity
we've got going on here and corruption
and by the way he's the guy that guy who
lied to this country for three straight
years saying we have all the evidence of
Trump Russia collusion he's a liar a
congenital liar and of course the idiots
in the media mob they are following
their beloved congenital liar over the
cliff again and today oddly enough
despite claiming he doesn't know who the
whistleblower is the congenital liar
somehow knew just when to cut off the
witness from revealing anything about
his identity we're never allowed to know
whistleblowers not a whistleblower look
at the statute we've examined it on this
program take a look as you know the
intelligence community has 17 different
agencies
what agency was this individual from if
I could interject here we don't want to
use these proceedings it's our time I
know material we need to protect the
whistleblower if please stop I want to
make sure that there's no effort to out
the whistleblower through the use of
these proceedings I only read out
outside of the NSC to individuals two
individuals task
and one other new person and you're not
willing to tell us who that other
individual is mr. chairman point of
order mr. chairman chairman point of
order this committee will not be used to
out the whistle blower that same mr.
chairman get necessity of the time so I
don't lose the doctor cyst you are
recognized again mr. Jordan mr. Chairman
I don't see how this is outing a
whistleblower the the witness has
testified in his deposition that he
doesn't know who the whistleblower is
you have said even though no one
believes you you have said you don't
know who the whistleblower is so how is
this outing the whistleblower to to find
out who this individual is Jordan this
is your time for questioning you can use
it any way like but your question should
be addressed to them I liked it and your
question should not be addressed to
trying to out the whistleblower
checkmate so does that mean that the
witness you just saw this
lieutenant-colonel vin Minh leaked the
call to the whistleblower I don't know
we do know Ben Vinson's expressed a lot
of concern about his judgment we do know
that Binh Minh never talked to the
president and never advised him directly
period end of sentence he seemed pretty
annoyed the president didn't use his
talking points we also know he was
unhappy about all of that and that made
him unhappy with the phone call with
Ukraine why did you use my talking
points anyway but guess what the
president doesn't follow a script yeah
he's the president he's the
commander-in-chief and he sets his own
foreign policy not some other bureaucrat
I know this might be hard for many in
the deranged radical extreme members of
the Socialist Democratic Party and their
allies in the media mob the president
one he's president he's the commander in
chief that's right 304 electoral votes
and yes he defeated Hillary Clinton in
Democrats want upend the will of we the
American people they better have a lot
more evidence than hearsay dumb frankly
worthless opinion and conjecture that
differs from person a person this is now
hurting our country and hang on a second
understand the Senate is never going to
confirm this charade Federal Rules of
Evidence don't allow hearsay evidence
that's not a missable none of it none of
these people will be heard in the
US Senate if there's ever a trial one
honest Democratic congressman sums it up
like this we spent millions of dollars
tons of money tons of time tons of hurt
fracturing the nation apart and I
haven't seen this to be a good thing